[Musik]
hallo zusammen ich bin andreas chrobok
normalerweise kennt man eher meine
stimme aus dem faz podcast für
deutschland ich bin heute in frankfurt
unterwegs ich wohne relativ stadtnah um
mal zu gucken wie viele leute auf der
straße sind und ich muss sagen so leer
wie heute vormittag die bockenheimer
landstraße die von alten oper zur uni
für soll er habe ich sie an einem
samstag noch nie gesehen
normalerweise ist da richtig staub jetzt
gehen wir auf die zahlen und auch die
freßgass' und guck mal was da so los ist
[Musik]
kurze stippvisite in der u-bahn kein
mensch ich bin jetzt hier auf der
freßgass' angekommen eigentlich die
beliebteste frankfurter straße an einem
samstagvormittag die leute haben in der
stadt eingekauft und hier gibt es
reichlich restaurants und cafés und bars
wo man sich gemütlich machen kann aber
heute normalerweise würde schätzen das
was man hier sieht da sind ansonsten
locker 1000 1500 leute heute kann man
vielleicht bis 10.10
vor zwei tagen war die innenstadt noch
voll die busse waren voll aber seit zwei
tagen ist die kundenfrequenz im
stadtgebiet komplett rückläufig die
leute sind wohl endlich zur besinnung
gekommen
also ich kann das experiment an dieser
stelle abbrechen in der frankfurter
innenstadt ist heute nahezu nichts los
sind nur ganz wenige leute unterwegs die
auch wirklich dringliches zu erledigen
haben
und damit wächst meines erachtens die
chance dass wir um eine komplette
ausgangssperre
doch herumkommen
[Musik]